if jason has your back jason has your
back jason will sacrifice anything to
make sure
yeah hold down the four frame me and
jason yeah i always support him he
always
i never i never not for one second do i
question if jason ellis has my back
he is all trying to fight and [ __ ] he
you know uh he's trying to fight louis j
gomez that's the next big fight
why did they not like each other no no
um
lewis actually came and fought at the
last ellis mania against another
yeah i don't know against end of the
comic and against another comment and
they both
really love me i've only been around
lewis like once or twice i don't know
him
yeah and i know jason very nice lewis
was very nice to me and i that's the
only time i got to know him was that the
only time i saw lewis fights when he
fought
um he thought come on brendan he does
the stuff jeremiah jeremiah watch
slap and jeremiah beat him right he lit
him up a little bit yeah jeremiah let
him up
but but but but size wise
because i'm not who's bigger he's bigger
he's a big dude but isn't
jason's way more well trained than those
right
this the only reason this is happening
is because lewis called out jason
he said i i'm looking for my next
challenge he's like i'll fight ellis and
ellis responded on twitter he's like
you're a good guy i don't want to do
that i
i will [ __ ] check you isn't training
so much more important that this
training and consistent jason's been
training consistently
15 years you know so uh i think a lot of
that's going to be
i would watch it [ __ ] yeah i'd watch it
proved himself to be tough man that last
fight i was really impressed by him and
that other fella
if you could watch one celebrity bout
the answer is not none no if you no you
just to see two people you'd watch
there's none
none really i hate all of it i love
jason love lewis i don't watch i mean
i'll watch it because i know him but i
don't i don't want to watch it because
it's so you know what i want to watch
yeah
dc versus uh yeah okay right
but you can't tell me if there was i
like the freak show i wouldn't watch it
every week that publicity stunt of
bieber versus tom cruise you wouldn't
i pay all my money all of my money
and that's the problem me too by the way
well like roy jones mike tyson at 53 and
you'd watch that i'm watching i'm not as
excited i'm watching it
no desire because i love them both so
much that's why
i don't want to i agree it's gonna be
sad but to me would you watch larry bird
and magic johnson
no not taking other shorts right now
have a three-point contest no
you would watch it you saw it i would
watch that yeah if you promise
if you promise by the way i'm watching
bieber cruise
all day a thousand percent all day i'm
watching
and my money it's just giving me a bunch
of mangling like in the grappling like
this on the feet
they separating with me one punch and
then back to this probably if you
think you're fifty dollars out if you
think tom cruise
beats stuff isn't going a hundred
percent in
on learning how to be a fighter
it'll be a black belt don't be a black
belt you could be a black belt in a year
dude scientology's paying for everything
every this dude and not only so hardcore
you would have to the difference is
justin's famous for too long to be hard
he's been famous from youtube since he
was like dude tom cruise he's been some
[ __ ]
you broke his ankle on mission
impossible you [ __ ] you're going to have
to
kill tom cruise that's my thing
he's
again i don't know this is lewis crazier
than jason no
no jake jason jason was the number three
skateboarder in the world at one point
right jason number one in australia
number three overall in the world used
to stand at the end of the mega ramp
with other professional vert
skateboarders and while all of them
were like i don't know he's going
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go and going seven million miles
in the air and fly and shatter his
angles he's like i better wake up and do
it again tomorrow
so it's what i do then fought shane carr
win
he got granted one handed told him he
fought shane carl
okay like he's jason is a i didn't see
that it's as hardcore
as they come but i i just on
for for cardio sake and for like ring
there won't be any like
jitters with jason because he's done
this so many [ __ ] times wait that
dude was one arm
yeah but he's so much bigger well hold
on [ __ ] but he's also a former
heavyweight champion he's also
notoriously known shane's one of my
closest friends yeah he's my number one
trading partner
shane's also the the hardest hitting
heavyweight of all time besides francis
if you're going let give a list of three
he's in the top three of across the
board of all-time heavy hitters
ufc and is he a lefty or righty because
he's hitting with his left he's a
right-handed guy
that is alive he should only jab and
throw hooks
and he can box his ass off i mean
but jeez that is so bananas look how
thick shane is
he fought 10 guys in 10 rounds back to
back to back
and like six of them were professional
ufc fighters jason jason's
he's crazy he's off you know yeah i'll
do it in a good way in a good way in all
the entertaining ways so you don't like
watching this
i like watching the [ __ ] show no i like
sideshow i hate it
no no no i guess probably because i'm in
the business of like the highest level
[ __ ]
so when it's a [ __ ] show like you would
you like watching would you like
watching
bad stand up over and over not over and
over but if you're gonna say
well like on on kill tony like it's one
minute and it's fun
but now if it's an hour of that okay but
let me let me let me say this
if you said to me okay hey listen man
um vin diesel's gonna do 20 minutes of
stand up do you want to go see him take
a [ __ ] on stage i'd be like no no no
yeah no no let's go see him take it no
you're not you're forgetting your one
key aspect
vin diesel challenged the rock to a
comedy contest
that's more of what we're going on yeah
i'd be like oh yeah i gotta go see
how bad is that gonna be i gotta go i
like the train wreck though oh i'm not
into it at all yeah
you like the circus oh i love the circle
invite me
i'm so not into it if you guys went i
wouldn't ask you the next day how it
went
i'd be like really and you're not going
to watch tyson road roy jones jr
absolutely not
are you yeah he loves it when you see
tyson
loves it when you see
but are you are you are you when tyson
puts out those
fighting the the the sparring or the hit
in the midst you don't like watching i
wouldn't watch them no
i have no desire i am a shell of himself
dude
ah he's 53. he but listen
if at 53 listen i
think he they should anybody jason ellis
lewis
mike tyson roy jones do whatever the
[ __ ] you want i support it
i hope louis and jason l sell 10 million
pay-per-views i hope everybody gets paid
people watch
i'm just not into it okay what about
logan paul is it logan paul or paul yeah
and he's fighting nate robertson right
it's his brother jake
jake paul wait a second i'm not into it
what if you think there's an avenue for
it but
what if you knew both people really well
what if i fought callan
you'd watch that yeah
not only would you watch that you'd be
[ __ ] honing down the moment he'd be
watching
it he'd be watching it pants off at his
house by himself
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe i think people
you know
for sure makes a big difference i i i
like
because i also like watching people
who now not forever but i like watching
people that's not what you do for a
living
but you're gonna try it i like watching
i'm not i do i do i do it ah
interesting all right teach its own i
think the the popular opinions with you
guys
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like you look like
a rottweiler you gotta [ __ ] together all
you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son